[Música]
a
[Aplausos]
hola a todos
el día de hoy les voy a hablar acerca de
un tema que los estamos escuchando cada
vez con mayor frecuencia que es el
cáncer ustedes verán que el cáncer ya en
el 2012
la mortalidad era 'la ya era alta no más
de 14 millones de personas fueron
diagnosticadas con esta enfermedad
imagínense que los datos no son buenos
del cáncer que es lo que dicen que para
el 2030 uno de cada cuatro personas
durante su vida tendrá un tipo de cáncer
el cáncer es una enfermedad
que nos está amenazando a toda la
humanidad a todos los países sin
distinción de raza institución de género
o de edades pero no tenemos que verlo
como una amenaza tenemos que verlo como
un desafío no un desafío nuestro y
tenemos que encontrar soluciones
hoy en día en bolivia estamos perdiendo
esta lucha no yo lo veo como una crisis
no solamente a nivel de salud sino una
crisis a nivel de la sociedad cuando un
país cuando un paciente viene
diagnosticado de este tipo de enfermedad
se encuentra muchas veces frustrado no
sabe qué es lo que tiene que hacer y se
siente y entra en lo que se llama la
resignación porque no tenemos las armas
para combatirlas todo lo que nosotros
estamos viviendo en este momento en esta
crisis ya otros países lo han vivido
eeuu hace 80 años lo vivían como verán
en esta portada el cáncer en ese
entonces era la gran oscuridad no se
conocía nada y la medicina oncológica
estaba atascada en una rutina porque no
sabíamos a lo que nos enfrentábamos y no
teníamos las
para luchar
sin embargo como les decía ante los
retos se tienen que plantear soluciones
y en los últimos años se han hecho
muchos aportes científicos para combatir
el cáncer entre estos está lo que se
llama la medicina traslacional la
medicina translacional que es no es la
ciencia que se transforma que se
transforma en medicina es la aplicación
de los descubrimientos en el laboratorio
directamente en el paciente sin embargo
no es fácil la interacción interacción
entre el médico y el investigador les
explicó de la siguiente manera yo me
encuentro en este tapete rojo es un
círculo yo me encuentro cómodo lo
conozco y estoy confortable sin embargo
en el momento en el que yo pase esto
entré a una zona que no la conozco
pero esa es la medicina transnacional ir
más allá de nuestros límites y conocer
qué es lo que está qué es lo que no
conocemos y al pasar estas líneas
nosotros aportamos nuestros
conocimientos a la investigación y
viceversa
esa es la medicina transnacional en la
imagen que ustedes ven
es una brecha enorme que se ha creado
hace años entre la investigación y la
medicina y en este momento se están
creando puentes para que ambas puedan
comunicarse
cuáles son los resultados hoy en día de
la medicina traslacional ustedes verán
en esta parte en la derecha actualmente
hace años que es lo que se hacía un
paciente que diagnosticado con cáncer se
le daba un tratamiento estándar y los
resultados eran muchos a veces eran
buenos a veces eran malos a veces no
había resultados sin embargo hoy en día
con los aportes de la investigación la
medicina se está transformando en una
medicina personalizada porque con las
con los laboratorios con los exámenes no
solamente voy a saber el nombre de la
enfermedad sino también el apellido
paterno y el apellido materno y darle un
medicamento específico para cada grupo y
el resultado no puede ser que mejor con
respecto al estándar y hoy en día es un
momento emocionante lo que se está
viviendo en la medicina tanto es que
este año se ha premiado se ha dado el
premio nobel a unos investigadores
equipo que aportaron en la terapia
celular terapia genética imagínense
de un paciente con cáncer quitarle sus
células y llevarlo al laboratorio en el
laboratorio entrenar a estas células
reforzar las hacerlas más fuertes
volverlas a introducir al paciente y que
sus mismas células atacan al cáncer y se
están viendo resultados increíbles
sin embargo no hay investigación si no
hay innovación los médicos e
investigadores o solo los investigadores
en su mayoría son jóvenes son personas
innovativas personas que tienen idea y
la investigación nace de una chispa de
una idea
y con esa idea se tiene que estar años
para demostrarla
pero qué es lo que yo estoy haciendo acá
y hablarles del cáncer y de estos
tratamientos que tal vez para nosotros
no están acordes a nuestra realidad
yo cuando terminé la universidad en la
facultad de medicina en la unsa tenía 22
años tuve la oportunidad inmediata de ir
a hacer mi especialidad hacer mi
formación en italia en la ciudad de
milán o
inmediatamente ya en los primeros meses
de mi formación me encontré con lo que
nunca antes lo había visto acá que son
laboratorios de investigación
ver mediante el microscopio células
hacer tratamiento estas células
inclusive darles de comer a estas
células y ver qué es lo que sucede
dentro de la biología celular la terapia
genética fue nació una pasión nace una
pasión y una vez terminada esta parte de
especialidad me postulé a lo que es el
doctorado no un doctorado en medicina
traslacional
no fue fácil entrar no es fácil entrar a
hacer un doctorado europeo pero se dio y
el tiempo en el que pasé en el
laboratorio que fueron un poco más de
tres años de éxitos y no éxitos
finalmente puede dar resultados
y los resultados en la investigación se
dan publicando estos tus datos a la
comunidad científica y lo que nosotros
publicamos y esta es la foto de mí de mi
equipo allá en italia fue como un
medicamento podría llegar a afectar una
enfermedad un cáncer de la sangre y
llegar a una respuesta no estamos
hablando de una remisión de la
enfermedad pero lo más importante de
esta investigación no es el medicamento
sino que durante las investigaciones de
manera casual como es en toda
investigación encontramos dos genes dos
genes muy importantes que son la causa
de una enfermedad cuando tú encuentras
la causa de una enfermedad hayas lo que
se llama el talón de aquiles sabes dónde
atacar puedes
crear nuevos medicamentos que vayan a
atacar estos genes y hacer que la
enfermedad se vaya esa es la importancia
y tuve el orgullo y el honor de ser
invitado bueno no de ser invitado de
presentar mi trabajo mediante una
presentación oral
al congreso más importante de un cuento
logía en el mundo que es la sociedad
americana de hematología y recibir una
premiación por el aporte que se había
hecho en ese entonces no tenía más de 26
27 años ustedes se imaginarán la alegría
y de este resultado después de tanto
trabajo
una vez realizado todo esto me
encontraba cómodo en italia tenía mi
trabajo tenía mi familia vivía bien sin
embargo algo algo en mi cabeza me
molestaba eso sí les soy sincero
mi idea siempre de ir a italia era
regresar a bolivia no
por qué
siempre siendo sincero mi trabajo que lo
puedo hacer en italia un estado si no
cualquier otro lo puede hacer y mucho
mejor muchos otros puede no estar mejor
de investigación pero sabía que
regresando a mi país podía aportar podía
dar mi granito de arena no aplicar mis
conocimientos en un país donde hay
tantas carencias
yo sabía que era difícil regresar no en
un país donde la innovación no es tan
bienvenida pero una vez estando acá
realmente me enfrenté a una realidad muy
dura no más allá de la infraestructura
más allá de las carencias la gente en
realidad no quiere que si no ve muchas
cosas entonces tú al enfrentarte a esto
tienes que pelear lo tienes que pelear
ya no te queda de otra sin embargo
después de haber peleado pasado tanto
tiempo
les digo
se cerraron las puertas entonces decidí
irme de bolivia no dije yo lo intenté al
menos vine aquí di la cara entonces ya
estábamos a 23 meses de regresar a
trabajar nuevamente en donde había
estudiado
pero cómo se dan las cosas no se cierran
la puerta se abren otras y tuve la
oportunidad
de encargarme en un proyecto de un
proyecto que link en acción ambicioso
que es en la clínica fides en la clínica
vida se me dio la oportunidad de
realizar una unidad oncológica con todo
lo que yo había aprendido y con todo lo
que me parecía correcto hacer
tres meses de trabajo tras meses de
trabajo y más de un año de
funcionamiento puedo decir con mucho
orgullo que esta unidad oncológica está
entre las mejores de latinoamérica y
centroamérica y aún con más orgullo me
da que está en la una ciudad que tiene
muchas dificultades en bolivia
y en latinoamérica seguramente será una
de las ciudades más carentes pero
pudimos demostrar que nosotros podemos
hacer realidad estas cosas
entonces como verán estas fotos son
siempre las llevo conmigo para hacerlas
ver porque no me creen cuando vienen
personas mis profesores de afuera se
impresionan porque no pueden creer que
haya este tipo de infraestructura en una
ciudad o en un país como el nuestro
pero el mensaje que les quiero dar es
que cuando nosotros somos jóvenes
ustedes sus jóvenes tienen que tener una
idea verdad tienen una idea tienen un
objetivo por el que lleven sus vidas no
ya sea el inicio de su profesión de la
universidad o inclusive después
pero tienen que tener si no les nace la
pasión y el amor en esto es difícil
continuar porque la vida es como un
camino nosotros nunca vamos a saber
dónde nos va a llevar ese camino pero si
no tenemos la suficiente fuerza para
para seguir a pesar de los obstáculos
nunca vamos a llegar uno de los consejos
que me decía mi profesor justamente
antes de regresar me dijo en el momento
en el que tú tengas la oportunidad de
seleccionar a tus alumnos
tienes que tener en cuenta dos cosas uno
tienes que reclutar los por el corazón y
dos entrenar el cerebro en ese orden y
tiene mucha razón y lo entiendo más
ahora que nunca si nosotros no tenemos
un compromiso un amor en lo que hacemos
difícilmente vamos a llegar a algo
pero también una vez que corremos este
camino y estamos cada vez superando los
obstáculos hay una cosa que ustedes no
tienen que olvidar la humildad una vez
que están arriba tienen que saber de
dónde han partido así como como dicen o
así como no hay cultos sin sacrificio no
hay ciencia sin humildad y eso es muy
importante y termino con esto les digo
si ustedes deciden tomar este camino que
es el camino a veces más difícil cuando
uno tiene ideas y quiere innovar en
algún momento las vidas la vida les va a
golpear como un ladrillo en la cabeza
pero no tienen que perder la fe
y lo único que les va a impedir dejar
todo es el amor y la pasión que sienten
por lo que hacen
entonces encuentren esa pasión ese amor
en sus vidas gracias
[Aplausos]